[Musique]
riches ou parasites des machines mais
parasites quand même autrement dit ne
sommes nous pas déjà devenu trop
dépendant de ces convertisseurs
d'énergie
vous avez sans doute entendu comme moi
l'excès en tout lui trop de misère sur
cette planète
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi
trop de chaussures à mes pieds et c'est
pour ça que pieds nus s'est pas
complètement faux mais on y reviendra
plus tard
de la même façon il faut être aussi se
poser la question
n'y at il pas trop de riches sur terre
ou dans cette salle d'ailleurs mais bon
comme la question est un peu polémique
on peut choisir de la formuler autrement
qui par exemple ici pensent qu'ils ou
elles gagnent trop d'argent
ne soyez pas timides bon je me sens un
peu seul mais c'est pas grave j'ai
l'habitude plus sérieusement la réponse
à toutes ces questions dépend d'abord de
la définition qu'on va donner à la
richesse j'en ai trouvé plein de ces
définitions mais aucune d'entre elles ne
mentionnent le rôle de l'énergie dans la
création de richesses
l'énergie c'est simplement ce qui fait
de vous et moi des super héros capable
de transformer leur environnement comme
aucune espèce plus exactement avant nous
l'énergie c'est ce qui permet d'avoir
des bills c'est ce qui permet de
transformer tout en chaise en vêtements
en cui pourquoi pas en téléphones
portables et donc il faut savoir de
combien d'énergie nous disposons combien
d'énergie la terre offrethun
donc à chacun de nous eh bien depuis 150
ans on sait que c'est à peu près 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie renouvelable
par personne et par jour pour les plus
riches d'entre nous ça peut atteindre
jusqu'à plusieurs milliers de kilowatts
heure par personne et par jour mais avec
un petit bémol l'énergie n'est pas
renouvelable
ce sont des énergies fossiles on peut se
poser aussi la question de combien de
matières de combien de matières
premières de matériaux chaque humain
dispose la bonne réponse à cette
question c'est en fait on dispose
d'autant de matière que ce que la terre
de recycler rien qu'avec des énergies
renouvelables et c'est à dire en fait
pas grand chose par rapport à ce que
vous et moi utilisons tous les jours
voilà un exemple de ce qui est
parfaitement renouvelable et recyclable
en fait autant ne pas se raconter
d'histoires la richesse si on la mesure
non pas en d'euros mais plutôt en
kilowattheures qui sont nécessaires pour
créer ses richesses et bien ceux ci par
exemple signe de richesse très moderne
et ben tu sais n'est pas du tout durable
dit soutenable et ça ne date pas d'hier
puisque il ya dix bilan au moment où on
inventait l'agriculture
les chasseurs cueilleurs à l'époque bon
on sait pas très bien combien d'argent
ils gagnaient n'est pas de fiche de paye
ils paient pas leurs impôts
pas facile par contre on sait que s'il
était vivant
c'est que comme vous et moi ils
mangeaient 3 kilowatts heure tous les
jours ça en scène est la différence avec
nous dans cette salle c'est qu'en plus
des 3 kilowatts heure que nous mangeons
tous les jours nous en faisons manger
beaucoup beaucoup plus à toutes les
machines dont nous dépendons pour
lumière pour la climatisation etc et
nous leur faisons manger donc une
énergie aussi indispensable qu épuisable
parce que fossiles pour produire quoi
pour produire 200 euros quotidien de
pouvoir d'achat c'est la moyenne des
pays riches
lorsque j'ai compris ça il ya déjà une
quinzaine d'années j'ai profondément
réfléchi sur comment sortir c'est à ce
moment là que je suis devenu en réalité
écologue c'est en réalisant que mon
empreinte écologique et bien était
tellement importante tellement lourde
que si tous les humains faisait comme
moi il aurait fallu cinq planètes pour
que nous vivions comme moi je vis alors
comment en sortir
eh bien j'ai trouvé de solution que je
vous livre la première c'est de chasser
tous les gaspillages dans tous nos
comportements
la deuxième c'est de hiérarchiser nos
besoins tout en haut nos besoins vitaux
loin en dessous nos désirs de confort
parfois légitime mais pas forcément
vitaux et puis tout en bas de la liste
nos caprices un petit peu futile je
parle ici à dresser la liste
j'aurais pas assez de temps pour ça
toujours est il que finalement lorsqu'on
va plus loin et bien je me suis dit que
comme il ya un lien entre l'énergie et
la richesse
pourquoi ne pas devenir comptable
carbone c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de
compter seulement les euros je compte
aussi le carbone qui est nécessaire pour
qu'on essaie euros et à ce moment là on
réalise très facilement que pour chaque
euro 1 d'euros
il faut aller chercher récupérer dans
l'environnement de kilowattheures et que
comme c'est kilowattheure sont
majoritairement fossiles et bien ça fait
à peu près 200 grammes équivalent
carbone maintenant un petit calcul assez
simple la terre les océans la végétation
nous recycle chaque année 4 milliards de
tonnes équivalent carbone
nous serons bientôt sur terre 8
milliards 8 / 4
ça fait qu'on a finalement une demi
tonne de carbone par personne plutôt 4 /
ça veut dire un kilo cinq par jour et
dans un kilo sacchi à peu près 8 x 200 g
ça veut dire que si j'avais un billet de
10 euros
je vous le montrerai et c'est la limite
à partir de laquelle notre compte en
banque n'est pas découvert ses rangs
avec 10 euros en tout cas notre compte
carbone lui et a découvert
on vit à crédit sur le dos des enfants
de nos enfants
lorsque j'ai voulu en discuter avec ma
famille avec mon ex épouse est bien là
fait de moi le premier divorce et
climatique de l'histoire et ça n'a pas
été simple non plus avec mes enfants
mais pour autant pour eux je devais
aussi aller plus loin dans la
transformation de nos modes de vie et
j'ai trouvé une aide aussi inexcusable
aussi indispensable chez les plantes en
observant les plantes non non c'est pas
du cannabis un sais pas c'est pas en
fumant mais c'est simplement en les
regardant vivent les regardant pousser
je me suis
du compte que si j'avais trop de
dépenses il fallait faire des économies
et faire des économies et bien par
exemple pour l'eau l'électricité les
transports la nourriture en 2006 à 1
faisait à peu près 300 euros par
personne et par mois dans le foyer
cinq années plus tard c'est est descendu
à 200 euros à peu près par personne et
par mois
toujours pour les mêmes choses alors
comment exactement et bien toujours en
observant les plantes par exemple pour
l'eau en utilisant l'eau la plus
immédiatement accessible avec le moins
d'énergie possible
c'est à dire avec une cité un qui divise
par trois ou quatre votre facture d'eau
ensuite pour l'électricité et bien comme
les plantes savez les plantes sont des
êtres vivants qui ont des aussi des
panneaux photovoltaïques à pile à
combustible intégré ça s'appelle des
feuilles et dans ses feuilles les
plantes produisent beaucoup plus
d'énergie qu'elle n'en consomme donc
j'ai fait pareil à la maison et puis les
plaintes stock très très peu et
heureusement sinon vous et moi nous ne
serions pas là parce que nous utilisons
leurs surplus d'énergie pour les
déplacements exactement de la même façon
les plantes pour vous son i mobile ou
fixe est fixée oui la plupart sauf les
sargasses mais en tout cas c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont fixés qu'elles sont
immobiles en fait les plantes savent
faire se déplacer ce qui a de plus léger
en aile les grains de pollen par exemple
ou leurs graines les plantes ça aussi
transmettre des informations
les unes aux autres soit en produisant
des gaz soit en utilisant leur internet
souterrain leurs roues du wide web qui
est bien plus écologique
d'autres world wide web il vient de la
même façon j'ai décidé de déplacer chez
moi à commencer par ma misérable
carcasse que ce qui doit absolument être
déplacé mais le moins souvent possible
le moins loin possible
le moins vite possible et puis pour la
nourriture et bien vous aurez de vider
comme les plantes c'est à dire en
rangeant de terroir et de saison des
produits avec le moins d'aliments
d'origine animale possible même s'il
existe des plantes carnivores mais bon
et puis surtout avec le moins de
transformation possible lorsque c'est
toute transformation nécessite de
l'énergie
en fait j'ai simplement compris qu' il
fallait planté l'humanité c'est pour ça
que je suis pieds nus devant vous pour
mieux me planter et pour mieux vous
plantez aussi parce que c'est beaucoup
mieux de prendre l'initiative
d'anticiper exactement comme les plantes
anticipe toujours le pire se prépare au
pire comme ça ils n'ont que des bonnes
surprises
si on ne le fait pas la nature se
chargera de nous planter six de ces doux
de nous plantons page
et si nous la laissons faire il y aura
de la casse beaucoup de casse pour
terminer depuis que je suis en train de
vous parler vous le savez pas vous vous
en êtes pas rendu compte
vous avez respirer chacune chacun
environ 1 g d'oxygène sauf si bien sûr
je vous ai coupé le souffle
la mauvaise
c'est que pendant ce même temps toutes
les machines dont on dépend en ont
consommé
quarante cinq fois plus quarante cinq
fois plus et pendant le même temps la
terre les océans la végétation de nous
offre que 32 g d'oxygène donc vous avez
compris plus nous utilisons des machines
pour être riche
- nous avons d'oxygène - nous avons deux
possibilités de vie nos enfants nous
regarder nous écoute
maintenant nous savons à nous de jouer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]